48 hours correspondent Erin Moriarty has
spent decades reporting on crime stories
she's covered all types of cases from
the death of Princess Diana to the
JonBenet Ramsay investigation in her new
podcast my life of crime she explores
some of the most famous murder cases of
all time Erin Moriarty is here Erin good
morning did you have to say decades
could you okay I found out you were
doing this and I have to tell you I was
like what well and this is so much fun
it's a lot of work because in the end
you know we're not just saying talking
we're taking people place we're still
doing crime it's still 48 hours at its
best this amazing team but we're going
places where you wouldn't normally go
including spending the night at a crime
scene which I've never done for 48 hours
in all those decades Lizzie Borden's
houses yeah well and right in the room
where her stepmother was found dead
hacked to death yeah what's so
interesting about this case I mean I've
never met a case I haven't been
interested in but Tony didn't really
know that much about so just for your
background it was a 32 year old woman in
1892 who was accused of killing her
parents with an axe
part of the OJ Simpson trial that of the
19th century New Bedford Massachusetts
right well in Fall River Fall River
sorry you know what she might not have
done it and anyone who's watched 48
hours knows how important blood spatter
and blood trails so if she in fact did
it and her father's body was found right
away there's no blood spatter there's no
blood trail right so there are real
questions and it's the other interesting
thing one of the many interesting things
is at the trial it was the 19th century
we weren't allowed to vote as women so
we couldn't be on the jury it was an
all-male jury and that really plays a
very important part in the verdict and
the verdict itself is very surprising
you probably think you know you don't
you also spend you also spent time in a
women's prison in Bedford Hills which is
the only maximum-security prison in New
York where I ran face-to-face with
someone I did
expect to be there because if you
remember Pamela smart and it's a 1990
case another high-profile profile case
where a young woman was convicted of
enticing a high school student to kill
her husband but it was New Hampshire so
I didn't expect to see her in the New
York prison she's the queen bee of
Bedford Hills bling pinked under her
green outfit and even pink high tops but
it was really kind of funny to run into
her and I went oh my god I think I know
you and she goes I know you too so
because I've been doing this for decades
you've been doing we have one important
question why did you give a stereo
killer your home address
it was BTK he was in prison and I wanted
his artwork there really is I thank you